-Our next guest is a very funny
comedian and writer,
whose hit off-Broadway show
"Just For Us"
is currently running at
the SoHo Playhouse.
Please welcome to the show
Alex Edelman, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show!
-Thanks so much for having me.
Oh, my God.
-This is very exciting.
You've done two runs
of your show.
You're moving it to
a bigger theater
this summer for six weeks.
And you've had people like
Jerry Seinfeld in the house,
Billy Crystal in the house.
What are -- What is it like --
excuse me --
on those nights
when you know they're there?
-I came in the night that
Seinfeld was coming,
and everyone was weird.
I was like, "What's going on?"
And they're like,
"Jerry Seinfeld is coming."
I was like,
"He's not coming to this show."
And they're like,
"Yeah, no, Seinfeld's..."
But he's -- It's amazing.
And the show's producer,
Mike Birbiglia,
who's one of my favorite comics.
So it's like having one of
the heads of my Mount Rushmore
of comedy producing the show,
and then other heads from
the Mount Rushmore of comedy.
And then, when Seinfeld came,
he said nice things afterwards.
And then it was like,
"Yeah, but what's the thing
that, like, you're going to get
back in the car and, like,
look at your wife and go,
'That was good, but...'"
And he went,
"I'm so glad you asked."
So, yeah, I got notes
from Seinfeld.
-You got some actual --
That's a very good way of
asking for a real note,
because I think that that
makes a person think,
"Oh, yeah, no,
this is what I'll say when I get
in the car, and it's safe."
-Yeah, but it's a very, like --
But Billy Crystal's --
The first show I ever --
The first solo show I ever saw
was a Billy Crystal show in like
October of 2006 in Boston.
And, like...
-Oh, that's pretty cool.
So, now,
for those who don't know,
this show is about a very --
a meeting you went to
in New York City for a
very specific group of people.
And I'm going to
let you explain it.
-Yeah. Well, I'm Jewish,
and sometimes,
people can't tell
that I'm Jewish
because of my name or my face or
anything about my personality.
But I got some anti-Semitism
on Twitter,
and so I started adding the
anti-Semites to, like,
this list.
You can make lists on Twitter.
So I made this list,
and I called it "Jewish National
Fund Contributors."
-Gotcha.
-Because every single time
I added someone,
they'd see what it was.
And, so, I started going down
this wormhole of, like,
anti-Semites on the Internet.
And then, because of that,
I saw this thing that said,
"Hey, you know,
if you live in New York City
and you're curious about
your whiteness,
come to this address in
this part of Queens."
And I was like,
"I live in New York
and I'm curious about
my whiteness.
And I'm free
tomorrow night at 9:15."
So I went to this meeting of
people who probably con--
white nationalists -- people I'd
consider white nationalists.
And I sat there for like
an hour and a half,
and, eventually, someone's like,
"I'm sorry,
but this guy --
I think this guy's a Jew."
And I was like,
"Yeah, I'm a Jew."
So, like, that's proudly
what this show is about.
I'm like, "What? It's not
a big deal or anything."
-But it sounds, like, so intense
and stressful to have done it.
Was it -- I mean,
did you go into it terrified?
-I mean,
I'm a stand-up comedian.
-Yeah.
-So, like,
I walk into rooms every night
where people hate me.
Like, that's a --
-That's a good way of
looking at it.
-Yeah. Like, a hostile room
I got to win over?
I'm like, "What is it? Tuesday?"
Like, "Yeah."
That's how it works.
-And, so, then --
And did you know --
While you were experiencing it,
did you sense,
"Oh, this is going to be
something worth talking about"?
-Not at all.
Like, I have
a couple of friends --
There was something
that happened,
and I was like,
"My friend David's
gonna think that's funny.
And then
something else happened.
I'm like, "My friend Morgan's --
Morgan is going to
think that's funny."
And then I was like,
"My friend Danny's
going to think that's --"
And every single one of them,
even the ones that weren't
stand-up comedians,
were like, "You're talking about
this onstage, right?"
And I was like,
"No, why would I?"
And so, like,
it was the comedians
and a couple friends
of mine who were like,
"You have to start
talking about this."
So, like, yeah, they pushed me
to make it into a thing.
-The show is called
"Just For Us,"
and do people -- When people
come to it, are they --
have you had interactions with
the audience who maybe thought
the show was something
they didn't expect?
-This guy came up to me after
the show with his wife,
and he's like, "You know,
that was not at all
what we were expecting,
because we thought it was
gonna be more like the TV show."
And I was like, "What TV show?"
And he's like, "The NBC show."
And I was like, "They made this
into an NBC..."
And he went, "Yeah,
the show about the family."
And, you know, he's like,
"And it's weird, because none of
them are Jewish."
And I was like,
"That's 'This Is Us.'"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And he was like, "Yeah."
And I was like, "That's not
the name of my show."
And his wife went, "I told you."
So it's like...
-Like, there's still
a lot of things --
Even if it was
the name of your show...
-Yeah.
-...who would go see
a one-man show
about their favorite TV show?
-Also, how can they
adapt it without
Sterling K. Brown involved?
-Yeah, exactly.
That would be
a wildly offensive show, yeah.
-Like, they made some
bold choices
for the stage adaptation.
-All your comedian friends told
you, "Don't do that."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"You should talk about
that white-nationalist thing.
You can't do a one-man show of
'This Is Us.'"
So, you are --
You're from Boston.
We share a love of the Red Sox.
-Ah, yeah.
-I'm a fellow Steelers fan
with with Joe,
and I'm a fellow Red Sox fan
with you.
And you had a job
with the Red Sox.
And based on
this I.D. card, Alex,
I'm going to say you were a
young man when you had this job.
There you go right there.
So, what are we talking?
How old are you?
And what's your job for
the Red Sox?
-I mean, I got a job --
The Red Sox were awesome,
and when I was a kid --
I got a job there when I was 13.
This is from when I was
16 or 17.
-Gotcha.
-I wrote the Red Sox
kids newsletter.
-Kids newsletter?
-Yeah.
But it was like, sometimes,
I'd ask questions
in the press room, and, like...
-You didn't have your own time.
You'd be with
the regular reporters.
-Sometimes, they'd allocate
me my own time,
but sometimes, I'd be in
the pressroom with, like,
the players, and they're like,
"So, you're --"
There was one player who
was in a slump.
He had gone 0 for 41.
And they asked him about it.
And I was like -- You know,
I'm 17, so I was like,
"I'll raise the mood
a little bit."
And so I raised my hand.
And he was like, "Yeah?"
And I said,
"Do you like bowling?"
And he was like,
"Who the hell is this kid?"
But it was great.
It was a great job.
Baseball's my favorite sport.
-I like that you thought that
that would, like, cheer him up.
-I was like, "Well, someone
should ask him a question."
-I mean, you know, obviously,
he's not good at
baseball right now.
What about the other sports?
-It was like,
"When you go bowling,
do you miss everything the way
you do at the plate?"
-What's 0 for 41
in bowling like?
-It's like 28 gutter balls
in a row.
It was so -- It was the best --
I love baseball,
because it's such a great sport,
especially if you like
an hour of excitement,
you know, stretched out
over the course of
two and a half years.
And, so, like -- And it was
the most rewarding job.
And, by the way, like,
I saw you perform at
the Red Sox team dinner.
-Yep, I did a team dinner for
the Red Sox -- very exciting.
-Which was so cool.
-And they won
the World Series the next year,
and a lot of people said
it was that dinner was pretty...
-Yeah, no, I heard that
around the office.
People were
like, "It was all Seth."
-But you --
We have a clip of you.
Obviously, it was the ALCS.
-I still get good seats,
so, yeah, I --
-You got really good seats
at the ALCS.
And the Red Sox
lost to the Astros.
But you kind of came out
a winner, based on this clip.
Now, just real quick,
before we set it up,
based on the clip
we're about to see,
it seems that you had a sense
that you could get on TV.
-I just know when cameras
will cut to certain coaches.
-Well, I will -- Can I just say,
the subtlety in it
really shows that you have a
background in baseball,
because I think
that there's a real --
Just see if you can even notice
what Alex is doing here.
Let's take a look.
-It's hard to say that
four games into a postseason,
but these are
the defending world champs,
and they have had
their thumb on their opponents
every game so far
in this postseason.
-Hey, listen, no
one's defended since...
-Very, very classy.
Very -- Getting your head
in there.
-Oh, yeah. Thank you.
You know, really spectacular.
It's so fun.
-Yeah.
Hey, congratulations so much
on the show.
-Thanks, man.
-I'm looking forward to
your summer run.
You guys, that's Alex Edelman.
"Just For Us,"
running now through April 30th
at the SoHo Playhouse.